in this video you're gonna learn how to
write the equation of a parabola using
the distance formula so what exactly is
a parabola well a parabola it's the set
of all points that are equidistant from
a given point called the focus and a
given line called the directrix so what
this means is that if you pick a point
on the parabola you measure that
distance to the focus and you then
measure that perpendicular distance to
the directrix these distances have to be
the same now notice as you go further
out on the parabola say for example over
here this distance is going to be longer
but so is that perpendicular distance to
the directrix or for example here that
distance is shorter but so is the
distance to the directrix so that's the
idea so we're going to use that fact to
write the equation of our parabola
in this particular example where the
focus is at zero negative two so right
there is our focus and our vertex is at
zero zero okay there's our vertex and
one thing to notice is that see the
vertex is where the parabola bends right
where it changes direction the distance
from the focus to the vertex and the
vertex to the directrix that distance is
the same so that means if we're going
from the vertex of the focus here that's
two units if I go up two units that's
going to be where our directrix is okay
I'll just say D for directrix so we know
that our parabola is opening towards the
focus okay something like that and away
from the directrix okay so it's kind of
bending away from the directrix opening
towards the focus and if I pick a point
let's just pick a random point here
let's just call this point X comma Y
okay this point right here and we know
that this perpendicular distance to the
directrix has to be the same as this
distance to the focus okay now notice
that when you're on this directrix see
how the y-coordinate is always fixed at
this height of two so that means at this
point right here is always going to be a
y-coordinate of two now that x
coordinate could be anything so I'm just
going to call that X you keep going way
over here negative 4 comma 2 or positive
4 comma 2 we don't know what the x value
about the Y value is always two so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
set this distance equal to this distance
so what we have here
is X minus zero squared plus y minus a
negative two squared take the square
root so that distance is equal to this
vertical distance here which is X minus
x squared and y minus two the quantity
squared and we take the square root so
that's just using our distance formula X
2 minus X 1 the quantity squared plus y
2 minus y 1 the quantity squared add
those together and take the square root
now all we have to do is let's just
square both sides of this equation okay
so the square and the square root those
cancel one another out here we have X
minus zero which is just X so we have x
squared here we have when you subtract
it's like adding the opposite so that's
going to be y plus two squared X minus X
here is zero squared is just zero and
then we have Y minus two squared Y minus
two squared ok go let's go ahead and see
we can simplify this down a little bit
further y plus two squared is y squared
plus four y plus four if you want you
can write this out twice y plus two
times y plus two in foil okay and then
over here we have y squared minus 4y
plus four now if we subtract Y squared
from both sides you can see that those
cancel one another out if I subtract
four from both sides you can see that
these fours cancel one another out and
if I subtract 4y from both sides you can
see this is going to leave us with x
squared equals negative 8y and that's
the equation of your parabola now you
can rewrite it I could divide both sides
by negative eight or multiply both sides
by the reciprocal negative one-eighth
and we could get y equals negative
one-eighth x squared that's another way
to write it and that's the equation of
your parabola so if you want to see a
video that I did talking about the four
different forms of the equation of a
parabola
whether it's a vertex form the general
form the intercept form this form
involving the focus check out the video
that I did right there and subscribe to
the channel I look forward to helping
you in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon